let's begin by thinking a little bit
about I wonder if you have any guesses
as to why I've put this picture up on
the screen who does physics whether
physics tutors chemistry you have almost
covered everyone our thinking has them
but even despite whether you have that
or not as part of your pattern of study
we are he knowses right this is stuff we
learned in new seven eight nine and ten
right so these models of the atom they
really fascinate me mainly because there
are so many of them the reason I want to
show you this image in this history is
to illustrate to you that there is a
really big difference between science
and mathematics at least the way we you
normally think about science let's think
about this for a second how many of you
feel pretty confident that you actually
could explain one two three four five
these models it not like in super detail
but who's like I know what these models
are and I can tell you about them anyone
heads-up I just want to generous I'm not
gonna ask you to do it I just want to
get a general sense of how well you know
it okay thank you here's an so here's
the general idea right throughout
history we have sought to understand
what it is that all the stuff around us
is made up of and famously the you know
ancient Greeks and that kind of thing
they thought that everything that was
around us in the world was made of four
elements does anyone know the four Oh
months were anyway yeah fire water and
and wind or air right so it's like yeah
everything is made up of one of those
four things or some combination of those
right but then of course we started to
think about how to you know certain
things didn't make sense we're like
that's not a good model for
understanding like they used to think
for example when you saw things when you
saw things they used to think of your
eye sending out fire which then response
to the thing around you and that's how
you see that's how it like rather than
light coming into your eye and all that
kind of thing so they're like yeah this
this this model isn't working for us so
we started to develop better ones right
so this famously is based on what the
Asian some of the ancient Greeks I think
was Democritus anyway it doesn't matter
they came up this idea of this
indivisible bless you indivisible
particle they call it the Aten which
literally means you can't you can't cut
it and that makes up everything and that
different things like wood or plastic
and metal or
they're made up of different kinds of
atoms right everything's made up of
these chunks and you can't cut them up
except we worked out of course but you
can't cut them up right does anyone know
what was that you can see it even in the
diagram what was the thing that we
discovered that told us this thing's
smaller than an atom so we did discover
protons and neutrons and stuff like that
but before that we actually discovered
these little they called them cause that
was the original name these little
things with negative charge even though
the whole thing might have had positive
charge these little bits inside which
had negative charge and we of course
came to call them electrons does anyone
know what this model is called by the
way arts there isn't you can see it
right so it's like this idea of yeah
you've got this object and then stuck we
did it like like in a plum pudding you
got these little bits these little a lot
of sort of islands if you like I'm
negative charge right but then we
realized that actually you don't have
this big thing that has negative bits
embedded in it there's this idea what's
this thing we call in the middle now we
called the nucleus right does anyone
know how it was that Rutherford
confirmed that there was such a thing as
a nucleus they don't know the experiment
yeah very good yeah what did he actually
do he's shot yeah he shot rays at this
thing right and then he noticed that
sometimes the Rays would pass through
and statistically all the times they
just they wouldn't go any you wouldn't
it's like where did this ray go it just
disappeared right got absorbed or
deflected right so he's like no no this
thing is not evenly it's not evenly
distributed there's a nucleus and then
we kept on going and going and going and
got better and better models and that's
sort of the model that we're on right
now even though it's almost a hundred
years old down right now here's my point
how does scientific knowledge advance
well we make a hypothesis and then we
test it out
you know this stuff with the gold foil
and the gamma rays and all that kind of
thing they couldn't do this back then
they had better and better instruments
you know these models now we've got this
thing called the Large Hadron Collider
up in Europe and just this phenomenal
multi trillion-dollar thing very like
incredibly expensive and incredibly
powerful and that's how we keep on
advancing in our knowledge right but the
whole point in science is we observe we
look we make a theory and then the
better our instruments are the better
our view is and so that's why we keep on
revising your revised
revising okay now in this way scientific
knowledge is almost exactly the opposite
of mathematical knowledge right
we don't make hypotheses we make
conjectures and instead of trying to use
like instruments and observe we actually
say can we prove this by logic and
that's why there's no the advance of
mathematics is not like the advance of
science it's not as though we thought
this is the way it was and then we like
whoops sorry it's not plum pudding at
all and we can't with a better model
we never disprove things in mathematics
you can't disprove things in mathematics
once they've been proven we use logic
it's not like oh I have better
I have better pens and pencils now that
can use me that I can use to prove
better theorems once you've proven
something true like this guy right once
you prove the relationship between these
three a squared plus B squared equals C
squared is just true forever no matter
where you are no matter what instruments
how precisely you measure and all that
kind of thing right so this is the
difference in science mathematics and
that's why it takes a little more than
just saying when I differentiate
something like this what do you get
we've done this before
done right 3 3 x squared that's what we
got right when you differentiate
something like this what do you get
remember you know 2x when you
differentiate something like this we get
we just get 1 think been a while since
you did one of these right last week
right but you look at this and it will
be tempting to think like the way an
experimental scientist would it's like
well look I've got all of these like
I've repeated an experiment I've
observed I see this consistent behavior
isn't that enough to say I think there's
a rule here well it's enough to think
about a rule but it's not enough to say
the rule is actually true here's what I
want us to think about if I have some
general power of X right what would you
guess when you differentiate that based
on this pattern what would you guess
would be a rule that should consistently
apply what are you a concern
and let's look at this for a second man
we'll start with this what's wrong you
said is see this power here the three or
the two or in this case the one right it
sort of seems to appear over here do you
notice that right it's like oh it sort
of becomes the well we have a name for
this the thing that's it's the
coefficient rights like the power
becomes the coefficient so there's the
power it's become the coefficient but
then something else happens right we
noticed this before Jemaine why is it in
minus one where did that come from
recen yeah you can see when we did the
first principles right and we
substituted in and we cancelled out this
the cubed or the squared or the one term
that was in first principles it always
cancelled out and you always were left
with one less than what you started one
less than what you started one less than
what you started so this is one less
than what you started this is a guess
that we could make now in mathematics we
call these guesses where they call them
hypotheses like in science we call them
conjectures so this is our conjecture
right if f of X equals this then what we
are wondering if it's true is where the
F - this derivative if it equals to that
okay this is what we're going to try and
set out to prove so could you make a
heading for me please which is
differentiating powers of X that's what
this thing is it's a power of X we're
going to try and work out if we can
prove that this conjecture is true
differentiating powers of X okay so
before we even get started on the body
of this proof we've got to set up bless
you we've got to set up a couple of
helpful pieces of information before we
get there one of them is over here on my
on your right hand side so let's have a
think about it right I've given you
three sets of algebraic expressions and
what I'd like you to do for each of
these is could you please expand them
for me the first one you should be able
to do just like that because this is a
result that you should know the second
one some of you might also know and
could do it quickly
the third one probably none of you know
so I actually want you
to expand this out longhand go ahead see
what you get can you do that for me
please